good well it's [ __ ] this Monday it's not
this Mike this money I am you now listen
I I look at the glass half-full bride
right I don't need you negativity she
came into the studio pretty negative
Rona back said he seized up last night
in the middle of the night woke up then
back seats up this morning back lower
back see that's where you hold hold my
stress you hold stress in your lower
back and in your hair that's probably
probably probably hair and lower back so
you dress cuts right through the
propecia I take what are the hands I
should say the finasteride thank you
yeah promo code fighter so why are you
so stressed just this whole corona
seriously I can hold down all the [ __ ] I
got a hold down the midst of a corona
virus that's what's hard you trying to
hold down just a month nut TV show we're
talking about podcasts we're talking
about touring we're talking about all
this crazy [ __ ] well well don't sip in
like ya driving me nuts no but uh Torian
TV leave me be leave me 20 V I know I
wish that was the case for me [ __ ] ABC
let me off the hook here yeah I know
we're shooting c-plus dude are you hold
up are you saying I can make the podcast
Monday cuz your shoot I'm sorry
Wednesday that's the problem if Joel
McKay I know he'll Joe Miguel Joel
McHale I'm so excited and I got a do
this [ __ ] and ABC's like get back in
there we gotta shoot these scenes I'm
like dude what about Corona and they're
like shut the [ __ ] up we're gonna power
through it now is the head of ABC Dana
White Dana White was the head of ABC now
he took over ABC that makes sense I know
you're lying I'm genuine so so so I look
to attitude today they're genuinely
worried really how worried I am worried
yes Jackson smooth now what were these
accidents move it's it's 1:00 in the
afternoon that is that 23 year old Tony
I'm call you a score oh yeah that's my
help me how worried I am how worried are
you dude every day it's 1:00 p.m.
yeah Monday you'll start where I am
that's impressive
that's impressive you don't give a [ __ ]
it's not that I don't give a [ __ ] what
are you gonna do dude I'll tell you
exactly what I'm doing I'll take exactly
you wanna know what I do
do i right i fret no bless you fret I do
that too I did I - I sucked my thumb me
thumb take my ass I fret my butt my butt
perks and I say the people I go don't
have money for the work you're doing
around my house but I do have a hole I
have a couple holes a warm mouth well
that's why I said to the workers I said
guys good news and bad news like this
and the good news that well the bad news
is don't have money daddy doesn't have
money
daddy on that money the good news is I
got holes so you got holes daddy has a
warm mouth and I'm looking for you to
pork your [ __ ] and I got and I got a
very tight starfish that doesn't know
what time it is yeah but here's the
thing he's open for business he's open
for you guess what fellas he has to be
he has to because boot business is
a-boomin we're taking the walks off and
if I get a little Crone up in my up my
[ __ ] I got a little crown on my
[ __ ] and you're open 6 a.m. to 6 a.m.
get this work done keep this work on you
understand and hey did they take that
payment um we don't know yet that's
gonna happen after the podcast please
film yeah I'm going to and then I'm
gonna sell the film online and make my
money back - so you see what holy fans
calm Bryan Callen this is a time for
opportunity this is not a time dude I'm
I'm you know I don't if you were if you
want negative [ __ ] and you know the
world it's doomsday you know and they
this ain't the place to comment cuz you
can get it anyway turn on the news I
could turn on any what we don't need
that man fortunes are made in crisis a
lot of times a lot of money was made a
lot of fortunes were made during the
Great Depression and and I think that
this is a time Andrew Schultz said this
very eloquently I agree with them it's a
time it's an opportunity to get books
read you haven't read to start something
you haven't started it's not easy man
it's [ __ ] stressful you don't know if
you're gonna have money yeah the problem
is when it's like three books or like
I'm with you and I'm looking the glass
half full - but and it hit me cuz so
many people do me a lot of people do
read a book [ __ ] I'm trying to feed my
kids a huge problem what are you talking
about have a book you like money for
food no I'm trying to keep my [ __ ]
light flat row that's I lost my job but
even read a book no but that's what I'm
worried about that's not that's 97% of
the world that's people we know very
dearly and very closely who don't like
I'm like you
don't have any money how are you buying
food your time I like to some comics
Maalox comic yeah there are a lot of
people that that live literally that
have 200 hours in the back oh yeah well
I mean the average I think the average
American is 400 hours are left in the
bag I was 600 or something but either
way thank you for this I think it's 400
this is a [ __ ] disaster
yeah but this is but this is this is the
world we live in this is this happens -
when do we get back to work and is the
juice worth the squeeze so what do mean
well so here's what I'm saying people
are talking about we don't actually a
lot of the data is still very very iffy
but here's the bottom line is that
unemployment might kill more people than
the corona var would you say 30%
unemployment or a depression a global
depression a national depression could
kill more people than any [ __ ] virus
could I mean in terms of suicides in
terms of domestic violence in terms of
all kinds of things that happen to
people when they can't afford to live
can't afford to buy food so I think
there gets a there gets the point where
we go hey let's get back to work
is there a way we can borrow yeah what
do you talk what do you mean hey let's
get back to work you don't think
everybody wants get back to work
everybody get back to what I do you know
I don't think there's an spread or a
pirate is not as if you don't plan well
the plan is to stop the virus the plan
has like that Italian restaurant you
roasted other rust no one gives a flank
talk about these businesses well south
of so many lives are being taken well I
understand I was trying to stop so I
first of all excuse me no they're not
being taken yet well we know that
they're not in fact I just spoke to my
buddies in the front line of this he's a
physician and he called me up and he's
my neighbor he said I can't even kids
play it with each other cuz I'm gonna be
at the phone lines I he's into UCLA
hospital and he's dealing with all this
and I said to him I go is it getting
better or worse he goes we just don't
know right now okay so we're still in a
holding pattern
we know Italy the fact is the fact that
matter is we know China well so shows
our South Korea and China but we don't
know we can't trust China we can trust
Italy because most of the people dying
are very old and infirm correct but but
with with South Korea they got a hold of
this because they were really smart
about testing they have testing boots so
everybody gets tested and they know to
quarantine themselves we
caught with our [ __ ] pants down here
that's a one good thing that comes out
of this it will never be hopefully will
never be caught with our pants down in
terms of not knowing how to deal with a
pandemic testing and all those things
it's a new virus I understand but we got
to figure out a way to get people who
are not [ __ ] positive in the
workforce and and and I I think there
gets there comes a point where you have
to decide whether or not the young
people we know are gonna live okay 98
percent success rate
yeah again all but all this whatever
you've heard whatever heard a lot of
this is bro science just to your point
we don't have much actual have injection
a lot a lot a lot of a lot of it's on
though we actually have some we actually
have some pretty interesting stats on
the on the cruise ships so they were
almost all elderly and they had they
think they think less than 1% mortality
rate and those were very old people but
the less than 1% because they got the
medication right now then you get the
medication they don't know if all of
them died of Corona those so here's the
other problem very few people have been
tested for it including when you know
when we have those rates of how many
people died of influenza old people a
lot of people do way more than but they
don't get tested usually so they can die
from other things so we're not sure but
usually that that is a factor when you
catch a bad flu you know we lose
something like it's a it's a crazy
number of people so we do have some some
petri dish studies some of them is one
of it one of them is the cruise ship
Italy places like that we also have
success we have some success stories
like China for example which I believe
is up and running what's the word and
and South Korea which actually never
really shut down correct me if I'm wrong
but I'll have you heard about again yeah
what would I'm spewing out something
I've heard other people talk about very
much spar on me but like you know where
the in Washington was the hotbed where
they had the really bad cases yeah up up
in Washington that old folks home they
got that medication that transferring
talk now and buyer medicine donate like
five million dollars worth of bails or
something like that for maybe just
straight up five million dollars or five
million pills for the medication and the
success rate with that medication that
they have to clear by the FDA I think
that's whether that's what trumps
timeout the success rates like ninety
eight percent when they take this matter
yeah what is it like I'm
and I don't know how many Sheriff so I
just think it's very I think it's a huge
learning exciting to rest of the country
which is we're not ready for this we're
not ready for a pen no one was though
yeah no one oh you got a you got we did
this has got to be here's the thing
we spent a fuckload of money worrying
about other things okay
and we spent a fuckload of time talking
about other threats according to Bill
Gates this is the biggest threat we face
something like this it's happened on a
smaller scale we got to be [ __ ] ready
for this so and there are ways you say
the young should go back to work I
believe you've ever idea
I believe that's that's what I think so
and I think it's up to the young and the
old to quarantine themselves if you're
an at-risk person I don't think you shut
down and destroy the entire if you have
world relying on health issues yes you
should it may be very hard and I do
think the people are going to die but I
don't think that you're going to save
more lives if we have a [ __ ] clothes
like Milan I'm with a hundred sound was
on you I'm on board with this plan my
only thing is I do you mind my buddy
Jeff Susskind like one most successful I
know smart dude black belt jiu-jitsu one
of my best friends lives in Denver
more time out Corona and I'm always
positive I'm like yeah but 98% success
rate and I'm telling my other stuff and
he goes dude hold on hold on hold on I'm
like what he goes dude I have a friend
you know him in Denver he's 38 years old
he's the most in-shape person we know he
rides his bike like Lance Armstrong
every day competes in races finishes
first
eats healthy than anybody you know he
got coronavirus I'm like in East 30s
yeah you will be the success rate it's
like 99% for that age group was that
yeah yeah
so he goes right that's what you hear
right he goes he's in he's in the
hospital he's not doing well but make it
I said does he have underlying issues
nothing no but that's anecdotal so we
know that actually according to the
stats that's a that's an anecdote for
the most part people who are young are
far more likely to experience mild
symptoms and by the way so I call it the
boomer virus every we got mad with h1n1
and certain things like that not even
the Boomer virus but it's it's though
it's the very very old virus so it's for
people who are 81 right stories
it's there's debris the heavy rink right
I don't want my my parents are 80 almost
I don't want them to die of course but
I'm saying that it you can't destroy
everybody's way of life and I'm talking
about boarding up restaurants and 50% of
the restaurants and stuff like that with
all who they employ you can't do that to
people
and I don't think that flooding the
market with government stimulus with the
trillion dollars or more 1.6 million
dollars what does that do I'll tell you
what it does it jacks inflation when
inflation goes up you got it you got
interest rates go up this kills an
economy so we there is a point where the
reaction the cure is worse than the
disease and I think that's what we've
that's the conversation IIIi think what
the government's trying to do is stop
this at all cost before it gets more
lives or loss about businesses they know
you're not a business yeah they know the
economy's gonna eat [ __ ] but they're
just trying to save human life so so
that that the smart thing here it seems
is that we don't want to overrun the
health care system right that's the big
things because remember if you overcome
overcome them with the coronavirus all
the other cases don't get treated as
well so a lot of people die it's not
just that they die of coronavirus if you
don't have enough hospital beds for
people who are bleeding and all the
earth they die so we know that well
again again caught with our pants down
again not really ready again hopefully
we go we take this more seriously but no
one was ready be well that was that's
true it's called a Black Swan it's
something that nobody could have
predicted but I think our our
overreaction has to be taken into
account and I think that's on them I
want you like to like this lady who
watches my kiddos comes over and she's
so stressed out like what are you doing
she's watching the news my god you can't
that there's nothing positive makes much
they create such such they've been very
responsive stress and [ __ ] just dire
times and stock up on this and do this
this person's dying this way a lot of
why don't you guys tell about China
right what about South Korea right what
about Germany right what about what
about what about no money or what about
the lady who is 102 years old you got
Corona and beat it yeah what about that
lady yeah
what about alt whatever what about all
these what about is a vast majority of
area you beat it you know what you know
why
can't do that though because then these
lock downs and try and contain the
buyers people won't take you serious
well they create this fear so I think
98% of especially in the u.s. are
shutting it down take it that's giving
them a lot of credit I would say the
media for the most part and make money
selling fear as usual and I'm not just
talking with the liberal media I'm
talking about [ __ ] Fox News
everything they make money doing this
and they should your local news ABC NBC
CBS
you can't watch you need that [ __ ] man
cuz you didn't think the world's ending
gonna blow your [ __ ] head off
yeah I told I told my girls mommy's
watching chemo stressed out but the lady
who helps out like killers like you guys
got a stopwatch right here all woman
beats coronavirus that is so awesome AZ
of course she has she's like go [ __ ]
yourself I've seen everything she's seen
the Black Plague at one 103 yeah so who
did their couple we'll find out who
tested positive we got some new
information what guess what information
in current events Oh Oh weird so yeah
yeah that your hair looks like it could
[ __ ] beat the corona virus hi could
you look like d'Artagnan people want to
get some positivity [ __ ] go carry a
sword dirty I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna do with my hair either my girl
asked me last night I was taking a nap I
popped up and she's like well you look
[ __ ] crazy and I'm like alright cool
cuz I usually wear a hat around the
house and then she goes hold on I know
what you know I tried what I you know
you're kind of groggy and redouble your
watches what's your plan with your hair
like I don't what I don't know well I
need to Bradley Cooper I don't know
thank you to Bradley Cooper status I
don't know your well your d'Artagnan
bring up d'Artagnan your Musketeers
yeah there you are I wish here you wish
I see a straight dude all I've ever
wanted all I've ever wanted if you
really boiled down Brian cowl muscles in
long hair that's all I've ever wanted
all I ever was was muscles long hair and
long hair like [ __ ] in your mouth
oh no that part hold on no I want to be
as honest Monday I want to say I want to
be a thick boy this way we're the
sweatshirt and I want to be I want to be
a little thick I want to be like dude
you're [ __ ] scowling this thick like
Gallants Callens [ __ ] sturdy right
like his legs you see is like I want to
be that guy no and then I want thick
black hair and I want skin the tans not
skin do you want to you want to be me
well I do but we talked a little bit
about my disappointment in your legs in
your butt right we talked about that and
that's fair right is that fair I guess
no I no big deal and also I have problem
with your calves now listen hold on I
know you have speed and I know that
people with small calves have speed you
a lot of fast which yeah I would like I
would like a more robust calf on you
that's not for me to set up to build you
know it is dude huh I wish you had good
hair and [ __ ] muscle it's not gonna
happen okay and I wish you weren't 90%
gay but it's not gonna have yeah I know
can I finish my point now with your
teeth or a straight not gonna have can I
finish my point
listen it's [ __ ] this Monday so let me
just let me just say a couple things
when I see you I thought it was honest
Monday it's [ __ ] this my holidays Monday
well it's honest Dave Monday because
because the world's coming to an end so
let's get it out there Brian came in
panicking let's just let the family back
see me panicking yeah my back seized up
but I'm panicking for other people not
me now listen no you're kind of talking
about yourself I'm a [ __ ] hunker down
I can bear down now you here's what I do
I see your shoulders I see your hair I
go [ __ ] great then I see your legs
like a [ __ ] this right they see my dick
you like oh god Pete Davidson special
and he talks about how Ariana Grande's
genius was to say he's got a huge dick
she started big dick energy yes so that
glove he said she's a genius because my
dick is not big she just has small hands
and now every time a girl sees my dick
she's disappointed and that fish
sabotage me that was the best joke for
me I had some issues with the special
joke okay but but I I felt like I was
worth watching it because now I know
that I probably have as big a dick as
people I don't know man you see some
pictures in his sweat and he's known for
having a giant did bring up his dick and
sweats how would you see this because if
you see my chicken sweats and I'm gonna
show it oh my god oh I should send you
this chin right now the star of the
Denver Nuggets
his name's Murray I think he played at
Kentucky
he said it's phoning out hat
posted a video on his IG story of his
girl sucking his dick and this is the
best thing you will see this entire
lockdown
besides Tiger King it's the best thing
you will see all this lockdown to see it
Murray wait I want to see peace dick
we got plants not for dick all right
it's [ __ ] this month it's like a
YouTube video that says Pete Davidson
continues to prove he has a huge dick
yep hit it hit that one hit it no either
way he is so matrix
my favorite player now I need to see I
don't know if I don't know if now the
viewers won't be able to see it cause it
will lose all video has a huge [ __ ] I
got Z's girl sucks the meanest dick this
side of the is that real High Stadium
well let me see this already he said he
got half to it and then I was like those
are just a random girl and then you
figure out notes his girl he's been with
since college you probably not gonna
post that yeah but also it says the
tweeze no longer available is that
violated Twitter rules huge black [ __ ]
let's see one kills of it what's his
name Kyler very yeah no Murray place for
Arizona um Ariana like said she's
basically in blackface you want get over
this huh you can't get over this Ariana
Grande but she dressed she's tan dude
she turns her body she tans her scanties
tan dude there's some pictures of him in
sweats but you can tell she's a tiny
little thing I mean is that good not
really no we just need a really good pic
of it I don't see anything there um
Jamal Murray
Jamal Murray I'll show Bryan just the
pic so you know I posted on I think was
instagram or snapchat
scene bear well well yeah dude we've all
seen bigger so what's the deal
he posted this on his [ __ ] social
media well I was dick getting sucked
yeah she's cute he's a star player for
the in the NBA oh and he said he got
half hold on
yeah no I know weed you know but I
thought you were gonna tell me I thought
it was gonna be this massive dog huh
small that's the guy yeah he's he's our
best player handsome fella he's our best
player he's a [ __ ] stud huh
oh wow first let me see his apology
maybe he didn't mean to you know how you
like your videos in your phone maybe
accidentally posted it pauses my fans my
account has been hacked currently
working on the issue I don't I don't
think his fans are mad no matter of fact
he's my favorite player now I was gonna
say he's now my favorite player I'm now
a Nuggets fan yeah this this girl was
really getting after it too it's Carl
I said that's his long time girls have
you said yep in video Jim already
getting quarantined [ __ ] puts on
this got three immensely claims he was
hacked who's hacking at 3:00 a.m.
mmm looking he was trending like a
[ __ ] yeah it was surprising so
it's more about the girl how good
choosing [ __ ] oh I see beastie that's
what really that's his girl she's bad
yeah she's a cutie it's a fantastic
video bring his girl out first it's just
it's you know it's just his uh it's his
longtime girlfriend so I donno if you
want to post that yeah it was just like
some song so why would you want to take
care of her
you want to make sure she's I mean a
white girl protected what'd you say chin
I said white chick cutie pie yeah
you'd have to go to Instagram what is
her name uh Harper Harper hempel Harper
hempel that's a tough one it's not bird
harp harp ball yeah I wonder if they're
gonna want them ba disciplines about all
things alright yeah me mm Wow she she
pride took her [ __ ] down to huh
Twitter Oh what's the spell oh yeah her
account and his counter says interesting
Campos know uh I thought you killed on
Twitter I know a lot of those only
fangirls post all sorts of [ __ ] yeah I
think I'm well she's bad II though Oh
cute cutie pie pie pie pie likes the way
the big taste yeah
knows how to handle it man cutie she is
a great [ __ ] she would appreciate it
right I'm gonna probably wouldn't watch
it if it's his longtime girlfriend oh
right Hey look at her body no you'd
watch it yeah yeah he's not so tall yes
she is she just super tall she just
heels on there he's a super stud yes
oh yeah super stud okay how I'm a player
great player all-star stud they've been
together since college
yeah she's bad told you it was a great
video oh there's a little snippet of the
video where oh here boy well but maybe
he posed with some tart it be different
I feel like I'm I'm being a voyeur he
most had but maybe he did get act right
although what's your phone I am how does
that work though well someone can hack
into your social media accounts okay and
then they post it but how'd that the
post edit the hack into your phone it's
all suspect they had to hop back in your
phone get your yeah right yeah
maybe the he they were super drunk and
he did it by accident was there a
caption behind it who the [ __ ] knows I
don't know that is a little bit weird
right things a nightmare it's fair to
say it's weird
yes it's not great it's not great
athletes are watched like hawks nowadays
everyone is yeah
everyone is they I'm taking the basic
you know there's no personal space
enough for anyone yeah you need to watch
tiger tiger King on that foot
I started its Sony episodes deeper I'm
in the middle of the second episode it's
a documentary on the sky in with the
tiger sanctuary oh oh he's a gay man
really uh husband alone with two
husbands what he's a tiger himself first
well that guy's a man tiger
it's he's such a character and he's
crazy the country singer it he does
music videos go you look up his music
video chin his name's Joe exotic well
naturally it's also a murder mystery
because there's this lady in PETA who's
in Florida who's trying to shut down his
business and the he like wants to put a
hit out on her so it becomes this whole
ordeal it's so dramatic all the other
tiger sanctuary people get involved it's
so fascinating
dude when you're selling online
especially in the world we live in right
now you need it to get there fast they
need Sony can trust I have no time
nope I'm talking about shipstation
dot-com fastest easiest and most
affordable way to imagine ship your
orders a few clicks and you'll be
printing out labels you can your product
out fast to happy customers ship ship
station makes it so dang easy so what
you get your orders how quickly you save
money on shipping costs keep your
customers happy yeah and I work with all
the major carriers including USPS FedEx
UPS Amazon they work with everybody
no wonder ship station the number one
choice for online sellers you'll ship
more and less time with the best rates
available and right now the tea fat gain
listeners you can try ship station free
for 60 days when you use the offer code
fighter there's absolutely no risk and
start your free trial without even
entering your credit card yeah just
visiting your credit card info yeah dude
just visit ship station calm click on
the microphone on the top of the
homepage type in fighter this ship
station comm then enter code fighter
ship station comm make ship happen let's
go
here's the thing Brendan went in times
like this you got to be thinking
clearing your body's got to be off
there is a virus out there I'm not
saying I'm just saying you want your
temple your brain everything to be
strong you want to fight off Corona you
wanted your machine you want the machine
oiled and moving at full and there's a
battle going on right now you can run
you got no I want to be able to slither
you better start on sand on it step back
move in better stop using I want a
healthy immune cigar shroom tech immune
they got biotech I want I want good
performance cuz I don't stop working out
do I stop working out you want a virus
that they like Ronin knocking at your
backdoor 24/7 you better beat them yeah
if you can't go to the gym suite how
about on-demand training with barbells
bodyweight kettlebells steel mace on it
six workouts on demand you can do it
from your home stay in shape don't go
the gym and get Corona stay at home oh
god go to the nutrition thing for a
second you want good performance you
want good performance Momonga and you
aren't you got whey protein you got
plant-based protein if you're in the
vegan stuff you got protein bars protein
bites you got a coffee shop you got all
kind of whey protein how about the [ __ ]
yeah coffee black right fork yeah on it
collab they got some freakin caffeine
crystals in it that [ __ ] will blow your
mind lets you know you fighting crowing
off every guy if I got if I got a book
it to the woods and really isolate I'm
bringing a fat butter my elk bars my
open Meg protein bars and my warrior
bars hell yeah daddy some kid oh hell
yeah old daddy compound cooking oil I
don't give off ya on it calm slash
fighter temper self the entire goddamn
website so it's the lady that he hates
so he hired this actress that looks like
her and talks about killing her it's
called here kitty kitty
he's say this not a terrible singer no
he can see pretty well i Jin's gonna
hate on it but you expect it to be
horrible yeah he's from Oklahoma
she's trash that I'm down yeah
when they told me he's making music I
was gonna be terrible it what does she
want him to do with his cats no she
thinks it's a thinks it's inhumane she's
PETA so he has these Tigers but it was
300 almost to do with those Tigers if
you have to put him down somebody's
gotta take care of him right well but
he's using it for a financial benefit so
he's making him do [ __ ] he's he's
killing him he's doing yeah he's like
take you in the malls and he's taking
kittens and then they're never in the
why
he just takes all these kittens and
raises them how would you think you tie
your cosplay not a lot probably because
there's so many of them in captivity
there's long cap to is not many in the
world oh no I know that they're very
endangered but because of habitat I
don't much is a cost if I wanted to buy
one
five grand two grand yeah but here's
where it gets dicey them bad boys grow
up you got to feed them so all the
Tigers he had he said you spend between
two to three hundred thousand dollars a
month and food in meat who's paying for
it
what do you mean so yeah that's how he
pays for it he has people come and come
to this just shows yeah why what does
she expect him to do with those Tigers
well I'm not gonna cut back I don't
think she gives a [ __ ] about I think she
wants to take care of the Tigers she
thinks he's you know using her and
mistreating and being inhumane and
killing them I said yeah you're not
pitas is he killing them he is killing
the Tigers why because you know these
are certainly age we don't need him
anymore so is he having them is he
putting around for canned hunts or
something
what no because sometimes in Texas you
put him out on a ranch and you can pay
to kill a tiger a lion mm-hmm what's he
doing shoot him in the head right it's
okay shoot him in the head
what K I don't give too much out speed
we're gonna wanna watch it's the best
I've met you on Netflix don't long it's
really it's fastened that's a Peter 7
part series
Peter girl alright it takes so many
turns and these other guys get involved
and then his mentor's that like kind of
like the Crocodile Hunter of tigers and
he was like seven wives it's crazy he
ever heard so in the bond or else one
girl gets armed [ __ ] bit off alright
don't show it don't tell me more they
show her AA video oh my god so in
bandar-log in the bounder logs which is
in India that's where Tigers for
whatever reason in that area attack
humans and there are a lot of theories
on why but there are fishermen who are
out in their canoes
oh yeah and they're fishing and the
tiger will go uh-huh
hunt some I'm gonna swim out in the
water and I'm gonna jump in your boat
pull you into the water and then swim
you back on shore and eat you and I'm
gonna come back for your friend and
that's what happens there's a book
there's a book on this and they did a
movie on it too
really yeah there's what there's a guy
who shot one of the Tigers like there's
like three Tigers shot one right took em
the Tigers ran off weeks later one of
those same Tigers the guys on the river
and it's hunting him the whole time just
hunting him I mean well nope walking
along whoa hunting them like hiding
where this is this is in part of Tiger
King no no no yeah I'm talking about
your story
yeah hiking there's no time though
hunting going on you need you later
sacrificing here's a problem with a gun
too apparently that when you when you
are like sitting there protecting Tiger
you have to have somebody watching your
back because they're so quiet they can
[ __ ] take you they'll attack you from
behind
and they don't break a twig under their
[ __ ] 500-pound body it's crazy to me
is this striking right obviously batshit
crazy preying on them you know how does
he know how to handle Tiger never bit
never scarred nothing shows him like
wrestling with the Tigers he has Tigers
Tigers just powder leopards you know
what that is powder leather hey come on
look at the size that [ __ ] thing
that's a Bengal tiger is that I have
Siberian look at the size of it mm-hmm
god damn that's a giant animal what you
learn is because they show like four or
five different big cat sanctuary you
realize they're all pretty [ __ ] up
really it's a dark world yeah you said
powder leopard stole on I'm not powder
cloud I might be cloud now wait not a
snow leopard cloud leopard yeah they're
loud about it Leopard yep yeah I know
what though
get you some wow I [ __ ] hate cats in
general I don't like cats I think
they're [ __ ] stupid but you know to
feature its own this and I'm aware of
them you know how much the house cats
would I be allergic to tiger I don't
think so do they shed man leopards are
so amazing though they are amazing
animals their speed their their stealth
there are such effective hunters their
small clouded leopards huh cat huh
Balak ass dude was selling these animals
all over the place yes two for two two
husbands gets married two husbands
one guy missing teeth don't give a [ __ ]
well you did that's a good [ __ ]
this guy's tough to see ya like them
kissing like wrangling animal well some
people are just kind of bad huh but
usually like they say a lot of times if
you're really in the animals you
probably don't like people that much
there's their who they are so check this
out homeboy on the right
super gay guy in the middle is gay as a
gift guy in the left is 19 he's seen the
cat he's early enough that he's night
raid [ __ ] monster hey she gets there
and he just wants to work with big
animals he's a straight man he's 19 he's
a straight guy in the car they're in the
car and exotic Joe goes how straight are
you and the guy he goes pretty straight
man I've never been with the dude he
does yeah let me ask this we watch porno
do you watch dude search for guys with
big dicks [ __ ] the girl or small dick
for his well big dicks he goes you don't
eat that straight because I only got
married really well then they got
married okay so now here's the thing how
did jump I didn't go they started dating
hate it went
you didn't you ain't that gay boom
wedding see he's a he's a looker that
kid six six six six six it's hey dude
he's got some shoulders on him too by
the way
yeah I I search for big dicks too and
I'm straight so you know I'm saying so
I'm not gonna marry Tiger can I give a
spoiler you want to know kind of I wanna
know if you're gonna watched I can have
seen it stop listing in three two one
so homeboy who is like not that's not
that straight you know what happened to
him do you know what happened to him
Brian well cuz he was a straight man
that was like oh I won't play with Tiger
snakes you know he's getting [ __ ] in
the ass in the mouth oh you know what
happens to him a year later he blows his
[ __ ] brains out in front of a tiger
Duke - alright to get that out though
we're back
Wow No Wow
[ __ ] well you have to get that out he
was clearly a loss sorry Italy clearly a
loss young man yeah and by the way was
anybody there when he did it could have
been the Tiger king himself you gotta
watch my car Wow hate ya damn it look at
this he's got this eye brow Pierce he's
every bit of my age
oh dude his mullet is just that the dye
jobs ridiculous outfits underneath he
runs master an appeal transfer uh I
think governor or mayor of Oklahoma
obviously loses he's on the master
manipulator he's a showman yeah see
those dogs that that guys holdin you see
those dogs down there those are my
favorite dogs you know kind of dogs
those are mr. Ortiz Troy's Australian
Shepherd got a catalog see I grew up
with dude I you did yeah look at me
lovin man all right
well they're paying the ass right
because they need a job in this super
hyper there's so this is just dogs
they're cool they're fast athletic smart
writer some of the smartest all right
goes with two huh grew up with two just
alright though alright dude you think of
a thousand other dogs I'd rather have
really that's his new man - he's not an
attractive man do but when you dude
apparently all they showing up there my
mother got another dude on their living
seven why his business plan was he gets
young dudes oh good good dude
so he hits these Tigers right this other
cat Wrangler puts him in a suitcase and
brings him to Vegas then brings in like
strippers hotels and stuff then it shows
homeboy he's an open relationship
just [ __ ] all these strippers and
there's they're holding clubs
guys no no girls hot girls because they
want pictures with these kittens
these baby tigers so he's like oh I got
Tigers they [ __ ] all the less the gues
picture ever so that's they have ever
seen my dude
the INA bats like what the [ __ ] am i
doing I don't know man it's pretty
amazing
the guy in the front when you see me
like that really are you sure you're gay
yeah it looks like a tough kind of tough
cat looks like a bit of a rapist
you know I mean it's raping that ass I
mean you know I mean like just he looks
like like gay men who are macho we're
like they a little scary you know
they're like well I'm gonna take that
having a guy in the bottom
I hate when we take this picture you get
on your knees I'm like I'm gonna go you
have Jerry guns knees these are the
greatest pictures I've ever seen in my
life
you know look at this [ __ ] hanging out
the front those khakis yeah fat dick
spirit yeah I was just busting nuts that
[ __ ] up some Tigers busting nuts to
look this Monday turning to Tiger [ __ ]
Monday didn't it look at that there you
go
this is great that poor dude was not gay
that guy is a [ __ ] character oh wait
till I got the Christ thorn like wait
you watch it it did he's such a madman
Joe exotic Joe exotic I won't tell you
he's doing now cuz I'm gonna support of
the show more but he's such a character
you realize that they're all fuck-ups
all the big cat sanctuary guys are just
fuck-ups yeah and she's busy hair she's
[ __ ] creepy they're all creepy dude
yeah he's probably over under bad guy
good guy in the middle complicated yeah
got a lot hate it complicated you gotta
watch it and you tell me what you think
all right
also died I don't know I don't I don't
put too much into documentaries because
they have a narrative to paint you know
yes so and then I did some behind the
scenes research after and Netflix was
like we wanted to do a follow-up on
where they are now they go but the way
we did the documentary we knew a lot of
the characters who we use aren't gonna
talk to us once they see what we did
somebody oh [ __ ] okay that's that's a
problem right because people can change
your story pretty easily a little bit of
a bad guy I mean but the facts and you
know when you hear what they're doing
with some of these cats I got [ __ ]
you're not trying to help these cats out
yeah
and you feel bad for the animals man
like there's just in these [ __ ] cages
it's terrible well Tiger should not be
in cages yeah that's all these [ __ ]
Tigers are they live in cages it's all
they do not have a habitat like they
don't have it's it's it's like
this room they jumparoo think they need
to roam yeah they do
yeah well that's a bummer yeah I don't
know if there should be I don't you
shouldn't be breeding Tigers in a
sanctuary shouldn't be breeding Tigers
and and and having them live their lives
in a cage and then and then it gets you
know then they gotta make money so they
make money off selling him so then and
you know and there wasn't a law forever
they passed some big cat lorry now it's
illegal to own them but I think as of
2016 you could just own cats and it's
all good it's not a giant tire so what
what Apple idea terrible would you do
with it you have to have a certain
license I think but no you didn't know
know that this they passed the rule this
PETA lady helped out though yeah crazy
right it's like owning chimpanzees -
people would buy chimps they'd be really
cute this is in the 70s you have a chimp
like this is the greatest prêt of all
time while [ __ ] everywhere but he's
also throwing things but also he's hood
eyebrows eight now he's nine now he's 10
and he's an adolescent and his balls are
dropping and testosterone was running
through his body and his face it used to
be so white and cute is now turning dark
and ran his teeth are getting [ __ ]
huge and oh he ripped my face off and my
genitals off and he's stronger than
three men well that's when does a chimp
become like a man I think it's eight or
nine they become adolescents and
dangerous in that big in that Tiger King
documented a show of the thing of Tigers
when they're good when you can have them
like do the shows and stuff it's only
like a couple months it's like six
months whether it shows here where
they're like in their prime yeah you
don't wanna know
chrimbus begin watering short distances
from their mothers at about eight months
of age chimpanzees enter adulthood about
thirteen years yeah that'd be a good run
with a chimp thirteen years your buddy
before he rips you're dead ecology yeah
here that one lady was [ __ ] him had
him in a robe given like Zane oh yeah
[ __ ] yeah and then one day is like you
know what dude face to she was what I
see chimpanzees mature our ways of
chimpanzees become dangerous maybe well
fast by age five are stronger than most
adults
yeah become destructive and resentful
they can't the [ __ ] wants to have a
chimp chimp tiger any of that [ __ ] what
are you doing dude I don't know people
want to be different you know it's so
weird
let's say people have snakes - what the
[ __ ] are you doing man what do you do
that snake I don't know like venomous
snakes like cobras and [ __ ] what do you
do with that [ __ ] thing can't snuggle
it no chilly you always gotta get my
sunset though and I watched these these
all these chimps these men were working
with chimps and there was a mature
female she was probably about you know
20 or 16 and this guy had raised her and
it was so wild to see she was so in love
with him that he would be sitting there
and she would just lie there looking at
him and Stroke his face with her long
finger she would just do nothing to that
see her face and she was just doing that
she just loved him I'm not into it and
so for her and him she was in love now
now try bringing a woman into your house
wish on Reaper [ __ ] tits up yeah try
bringing a woman in your house see what
happens
she's a woman Riddick the lips off yeah
yeah that's right you can't heal be a
weird dude to get that ball sleep in a
gorilla monkey to man or chip I feel be
a strange person I think so dude hey hey
your friend what are you doing
hole friend up yeah could hang you know
the chimp can have a conversation with
it that's right female a crazy [ __ ]
started dating that chimp straight up
dating dude yeah can you imagine while
she was taking bathroom let's take it
easy no dreams picture him in bed with
wine glasses and had a robot all right
we'll take it easy and he was a
200-pound animal and she was sucking
that chip off and I'm sure maybe there
was some chimp pretty lame pictures I'll
shoot sucking that chimps dick
oh yeah chimp is just hanging around for
the xanies and the [ __ ] wine I don't
know that poor woman that that the nuts
that [ __ ] must have busted on that ah it
got messy dude should bed took baths
yeah just look at her face food wine and
long-stemmed glasses
they took baths it color
cult cuddled in a bed they shared trust
brush the lonely widows here each night
damn if I left with only get upset
experts say usually unusually human
relation is would have been confusing
for any animal it may have also played a
role in Travis savage tech Monday on
Carl's friends 55 year old Charlie Nash
of Stanford poor thing
chin its [ __ ] your Monday hit that 911
call for me really I can't hear it I
can't hear it I'll relay terrifying oh
is it
yeah look at her face now you know I
know I don't see her face I was better
now though Kyle's here pal let's see the
picture was her friend though so let me
see the sexy picture turn that that's
her she got a face transplant look what
you see the features of the sexy chimp
in her I feel bad for that woman to
though did she just walked in this
[ __ ] psycho about is my woman our own
the chimp to she didn't she you saying
cuz she lost her best friend well also
to see that and to be responsible for
that and all that stuff look how crazy
but also but also don't dress him up
like Lea's basketballs well you know I
think a lot of times this was ignorant
basketball [ __ ] done but this was his
whole you know what the [ __ ] was up
dangerous this far I think she knew she
thought he was they don't know any of us
didn't tell you you guys are base by the
way he was very fat his face is free he
was I had patty his tits keep well they
look keep going that's the one they got
their face ripped off damn yeah I want
to see the other sexy picture this chimp
in bed with wine do you think they'll
have pictures of him in bed with one
yeah they know they have it I've seen it
he was on [ __ ] no you don't see that she
had her face ripped off that chimp like
this yeah a bitter face off oh did he
bite yeah that's terrible
there is with like McDonald's and [ __ ]
yeah it's not pay but chimps doing chimp
[ __ ] dude you know I don't put a chimp
in your house face transplant thank God
well [ __ ] tough man they stop and
figure out that face transplant thing
out there they saved the movies the st.
Nicolas Cage Travolta dude I hope that
doesn't go that smooth I hope they do
and they will know I hope they do to me
the war vets and [ __ ] like that I hope
they do man that's just tragic that
[ __ ] chimp though you dumb [ __ ]
that was a colossal tragedy all the way
why don't you put him in m1 shorts now
why was he in one shorts and feeleth
just on the on the on the stoop just
like clucking then she's behind him man
the [ __ ] are you thinking dude she died
of cancer too
she died of breast cancer that that
woman calm the stress they shot the
chimp down yes so the moral story on
[ __ ] this Monday is no chimps fur for no
chimps no Tigers no lions don't get
parrots either because they [ __ ]
really smart yeah they want to fly they
want to fly and no dolphins please and
no [ __ ] killer whale if they no
turtles either III would agree with you
on that
no turtle definitely no [ __ ] I do that
snakes and turtles can come back it's
not like snakes like I need to be free
they live in a hole but we gonna do with
it how about this in India you've seen
that snake that bit that strippers titty
yeah did you hear this in a rap video
yep
did you hear the story about India she
died I believe that woman no she died
did you hear the story about it about
[ __ ] in India they the guys could
they could tell an earthquake was coming
and everybody slept outside that night
do you know why all the snakes came out
of the walls
and all these Cobras were everywhere
yeah let me see this I think all right I
know she that's that's a different this
is her I'll time on that trap Queen and
got bit Jen look yeah she's in a music
video I think not this one no she was
doing some dance and the snake bit her I
thought she died that little zany a
little easier some [ __ ] got bit too
right on the hands trying to be all cool
with a snake you know he's all yo [ __ ]
my [ __ ] I got to ask Allah gosh he's
like oh [ __ ] I got bit y'all yeah that's
not good snakes doing snake [ __ ] though
you know that's right that's right well
it's like when people at the pet store
so my son is a bearded dragon a bearded
dragon they stink
so does the sand and you feed the beard
of dragging a bunch of worms Mellie's
ass well I had right to you now here's
the thing you can also buy you can also
[ __ ] buy
a goddamn tarantula or scorpion there's
some tits oh [ __ ] [ __ ] dude got her tits
her tits and that's what ha got your
tits that's what you do don't be a
[ __ ] idiot yeah [ __ ] now snails
robbing dieters that the teeth go in
they go this way gosh
so now you got to just let the snake let
go yes the pole cuz you're gonna have a
problem you have backed it up yeah or
cut the [ __ ] snake's head off right
there yeah no one's doing that dude yeah
see she's okay yeah is she mentally I
know but her the bikini right there I'm
see when she was a little younger when
she's younger is fun older it's a mess
yeah you're trying to hold on as you're
pretty it's like me getting plastic
surgery yeah so when they have they have
trenched that onto us and giant bird
spiders you know the bird demons
translates they sell those they're that
big
now certain transfers are for whatever
reason they don't bite you the big one
the bigger they are usually the less
thing yeah but if you see the size of
those mandibles I'm not picking that
[ __ ] up then there are ones that do
bite you and I was there when when
somebody I know who I did a TV show with
it got bit she was at the pet store and
she decided to pick it up and it went
okay
that's on her they laid her right on the
[ __ ] head that's not hurt and I was
like bullets a transfer he's not
attached to you he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you know these asuma's trying to
hurt him yeah and you picked that
[ __ ] thing up and they have huge
chicken googled people getting bit by
tranches see that it's [ __ ] this Monday
everybody time to watch that I'm to us
white people I wonder what the word well
I'm actually that's a one thing I'm
squeamish about a big spiders centipedes
snakes or sliders I mount kit snakes I'm
fine keep the other keep the big spiders
and [ __ ] away from me I'm I don't like
them okay that's our boy getting bit by
spider yeah baby already don't see this
one though by the world's largest
rancher pay off easy yeah hell yeah
I would never do a show like this no
Bryan's of course not
oh that's the [ __ ] Oprah ride rewind
that's the giant is that that Pepsi was
that's the no no no that's the Japanese
that's the Japanese wasp what kind of
spider is it by the way you're getting
oh my what did you see the vein that
yeah oh [ __ ] [ __ ] fasten all the juicy
[ __ ] did you see his arm on wow he
doesn't want to buy them do he's like
now on why would I bite you man we're
cool look at the size of those man
apples chance is like oh oh they put
sound effects too macho dude oh wait
this can let it keep them
I felt that mate it doesn't seem like it
seems alright well that may be handsome
in there dude look at that
hey let me get in there like you know I
thought it'd be well hold up what's that
look at his arm no don't look terrible
yeah yeah hey what if discovery kills
hey Brian Brennan won't you find the kid
right and Harris outwits call fine kid
wild and so ring give Brian five million
Brendon five million and we take you all
around the world and you got a get bit
by the worst [ __ ] insects in the
world and snakes five mil five million
in a - a year - no it's just one season
one season 12 episodes yeah we're done
thing we have to do it five melted five
mil in in this coronavirus situation I
pay off my houses as I'm vulnerable and
I don't want to be you stressed out
right now yeah I'll take some stains
I gotta get stung by some bad [ __ ]
though the worse the worse coyote
Peterson's an executive producer and he
picks them apart oh oh oh have a fever
Oh daddy I hate to do this what you know
if you get it you dad what I'm not any
hate risk you are though you love your
percentage is so much higher than when I
say on my last on my on my on my
deathbed I thought no this is you on
your deathbed ready yeah
[Applause]
you just go with you you were the one
why you be the one was the one what I
want them say he's usually some my wife
they're talking about it yes and I got
like no no please don't confuse him the
woman I come back tonight no you you big
[ __ ] fix just keep on that I'm all
wet Mike everybody gather round but I
won't say something else your ass is
built for power not for [ __ ] though I
have a nice for us any last wishes Brian
Ryan are you okay you have any yeah yeah
you look all old and sick your ass is
gone your skin's yellow like mr. burns
Oh grab my wish you [ __ ] off
well that was kind of a darkish [ __ ]
sorry guys oh sorry everybody
sorry about my [ __ ] comment but it's
[ __ ] this Monday if you can't laugh go
[ __ ] yourself
I am done near to putting that much you
need to send us more two guys oh I can't
cuz I can't function when I have a sip I
gotta wait over the night time really
yeah I saw you and uh Oh Brian came over
my house yeah guys do for your birthday
oh nothing oh I ate I watched I watched
the movie nineteen seventeen ten minutes
my god man's gonna be sick wake up why
is there only one guy left
yep I do that too I fall asleep all the
time
you're I had a good time though we with
Brendan I get together you know we do we
gossip that's what we do
we [ __ ] gossip Chatty Cathy's right
Brian bruh
Brian brought over some cheese yeah now
yeah I want to take a fat hand to your
face it's right over like a warm brie
why open now
sometimes I get your drags goat cheese
my whole house smelled like [ __ ]
Smouse it's not like a foot it smell
terrible
yeah it's not like a why'd you do that I
don't know man sometimes this is fun no
thanks come to the crib dude sure I'd
come over more often but you know you
leave your help Congrats on see you yeah
later
um no traffic so you get to the crib
fast right oh yeah you know how long it
takes me hits to do 18 minutes I like
that because I will save the
environments taking a little break huh
that the water the water down in on
Hawaii Venice canals dolphins were in
those Monza's ball Fonzie's Wow in Italy
first time ever they see fish in like a
hundred years is that true what yeah
bring it up how clean Venice yeah wow
it's amazing dude I'll tell I was
telling chin this - I'm below the belt I
went hiking yesterday and we took this
horrible you know virus to get people to
start exercising they're showing off
mental here on Italy's waterways I
thought we were talking with the ones in
Osama both Wow
dolphins are up in both waters dog I
might have made that up about Venice but
I'm pretty sure I thought it was kind of
hell away I thought it was both wow
that's nice that cool look how clear the
waters first time they spend that clear
he's just real mercury coupe in water
that's gorgeous
goddamn it I never been to Venice have
you oh do I go there all the time ago
that today all the time I want to go
there we go clearly how much clear the
water is dude yeah gorgeous oh you
should go there now boomer oh well right
I would I would go get you a $40 take
everything's closed though all the
restaurants you came flying in Bubba
well what the [ __ ] is that wild boar yes
you wild boar wait what was that was
that a whale these are dolphins you know
dolphin bro so cool
[ __ ] dolphins how great is that what
we're talking about of that you can see
fish though we are water dude Oh what
else yeah look at the week of the
fishies ah type in Venice la canals but
also I've never seen so many people
exercise it people out with their kids
like that trail that a hike on there's
not a ton of people there yesterday
packed packed and then driving it I see
people walking getting exercise have you
[ __ ] keep this up just not
because the Coronas keep this up
year-round all the time man I think I
heard something about the LA public
parks and beaches being shut down
because of that soon well already well
parks are shut down and beaches are shut
down
but like trails they can really shut
down yeah I'm not I'm out under each I
will not be respecting that I will be
living my life on the entire hiking hi
this where what I kind of resent I have
to say and I may take some [ __ ] for this
is how easily some politician I don't
know anything about can shut down my
entire life without any kind of it don't
like the job nerve la yeah but I'd like
a little I don't know leave the smog
there's no snow education hey dude look
at the positive dude before I know
you're right if I choke out not you're
not really have to [ __ ] you do have
to look at positive you know you know
why you have to Brian cuz they I don't
have a choice yeah that's right just
guess what you call the governor's
office yeah complain to him let me know
it goes for you I just don't think
there's any there's enough communication
but maybe people just don't know at this
point I think we that can we came to the
regular people even what yeah we used an
your house let us figure it out hmm
and you're gonna my problem with the
government the government is that well
they done with the with the I don't
trust the government for that to solve
problems how are they do with the
homeless problem I don't solve problems
very well politicians you know it always
move to Russia Papa you don't like what
we're doing here it's very quiet there
one crop economy though well if you
don't like what we're doing here dude
you should be texting right now that's
what you should be doing yeah I'm just
looking to see if I was getting it you
know I'm in a fight right now with
somebody that's what he came a little
salty - yeah with a [ __ ] contractor
who's not doing a good job I got to
learn patience I'm a 53 year old man who
doesn't have patience you a member of it
I got anger issues but you know what you
know what I go dark and now you're not
gonna like this and I like this but you
paid these [ __ ]
yeah Papa I bet you know I've had one
five houses now I never pay up for I pay
half up front right if the job's done
according to
patience the other half what I did you
ain't getting another habit up to we're
installments here's the problem what
Pablo's being stolen from oh yeah and
you know you can make it a legal issue
but I'm not because well then you got
lawyer fees yeah and those people
already don't have money and also were
you'll assume for us but yeah and it's
just it's Dodge Ram you get you get you
get basically robbed in one way or
another and it is what it is and you
just gotta eat a dick and go mmm
learn from it next time here's what you
do you you get what you paid for and
when you go when you don't do your due
diligence with somebody and you just
think that they did this some people do
really well in one area of their life
and you think they're gonna do well in
something that's way more complicated
like building or remodeling there's so
much more or dealing with your finances
we learn the hard way as well by our
correct sir babies learn the harder now
now we're a little bit excused there
because we came highly recommended
[Laughter]
that's you but but wait I want you to
tell me what was going on with me and
you what do you mean the financial
people well hold on hold on for a sec
I'll get back but I want you to that for
twenty years and I know other actors a
lot of money recommend a real famous
star good friend of ours like you got to
go with this guy we've been with her for
20 I was like all right went to him
seemed like fine and dandy sure he
looked identical the guy without the
hair from Joe exotic whatever yeah but
did that didn't work out then it turns
out that there was I had an ATM card
that I was using as an ATM card well
problem was they both connect that
account it's a business account it's the
fire one hit account let's put all my
stuff on there yeah sold Brendan here
owns half is Tesla right what Brendan
here them horses yeah I'm gonna go for a
ride Wow hey man take it easy Bob this
really stinks brother house brother
brother
brotherbrother what brother Monday
Wednesday Fridays papa needs it brother
I pay for half of it brother you know it
comes and goes right comes and goes
Rhona comes qur'anic Oh stealing money
from me comes and go alright for like
two years brothers for five years it's
45 years four years brother hey you know
what's great I think when we take you
learning less from this what did I do
about it right what do we do about it
nothing nothing
well we're all paid up it's fine but
still it was B but again I don't care
now we're good
brother brothers huh cuz brother we're
brothers we're brothers what's mine is
yours you know to me one of your kids
might look more like me who gives a [ __ ]
I don't know you know I'm saying it
doesn't matter it is what it is we share
let me move in during Khurana let me
move in can't dude I'll tell you what my
son we accept ellos papa are we going to
school today I went now dude the
sickness I tried to explain it to him
even though he's four I tried explain to
you just see that he's like why can't I
see my friends like yeah it's bunch of
bummer you want to hear my impression
I've had three very liberal people call
me you want to hear my impression of
them now is during Khurana ready like
hey do you think I should get a gun
Oh God totally anti-gun now sudden uh
where would I get a gun if I wanted to
get a guy what kind
I'm not joking my boy suplex and Philly
they own like the top sinker shop there
loves like salt the earth guys are great
for my birthday sent me these shoes and
I was talking with them and like how is
it out there man cuz they announced that
the police force isn't gonna arrest
anybody for minor crimes like car theft
or oh yes yes they say in San Francisco
yeah so will Philly there's some bad
cats in Philly Phil of it
oh cool bro and it's [ __ ] the purge
out there huh so he's like we're still
open dude but we got guards we got guns
out front like we're loaded up yeah I'm
like what the [ __ ] were they think I
think San Francisco or something about
that they weren't gonna add they weren't
gonna punish bring bring up like Fillion
outfit Philly like was like attention
everybody
if you're a steal Philly right now not
[ __ ] around know
cops are like why Philadelphia what laws
don't uh yeah it'll be like in their
most current news so Philly law news or
something like that loss carnivores
Philly Institute's stay-at-home order
effective Monday nope no it's all Corona
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
feeling I turn a blind eye to crime
that's them track coming their ass and
go mad what go back one is underneath
that Philly police delay arrests in drug
theft prostitution you click on it yeah
it's not loading very doesn't you think
it's just drugs theft prostitution and
you know but theft is a wide category do
ya
so it's mayhem out there mm-hmm I think
the big thing is how long is this gonna
be going on you know they don't know
talk to this fight these firemen down a
Manhattan Beach were I was walking on
the beach and these firemen came down
this guy was on his bike and he was
basically like just lying outside older
guy and there was somebody mentioning
when our cot X I don't know yeah and
they said I said how bad how bad is it
he gotten worse or better and he goes a
lot worse what do you mean nothing
what do you mean well they just keep
getting called for all kinds of [ __ ]
that's going on which is surprising I
thought it'd be a lot quieter but he
said that they're on they're working
more now than they did a little crimes
down though crimes down that was a
misfire he's a fireman fireman saving
life like people getting maybe it's the
stress I don't [ __ ] know but it was
really it was like hmm maybe just in
that area yeah maybe just him maybe busy
as [ __ ] well yeah crimes down delay
arrests for some nonviolent crimes yeah
let's do some [ __ ] tournament some
cred events let's do some current some
current a vans daddy's daddy stressed
out yeah my back seized up my lower back
seized up and now weird that's right
that's where I get it feel stress my
lower back well you know what's next
hey my psoriasis coming in hot psoriasis
oh you think your last bad now let's
bring back the itch bring back here
bring back the itch we're gonna go on
your face on your face on my face start
on my scalp and start on my face dem a
dick then the big stuff never got out of
my day
Sinnott Jim believes we closed all but
no one's talking well no [ __ ] the gyms
closed hold on all Jim look it they're
not my gym not my home gym bro oh yeah
my home gym open for business
work out in the parking lot David oh
here we are
okay so this was submitted by Michael
Anthony and he wanted to say that you
called it Harvey my dream to do to test
positive for the coronavirus he has it
he's in jail he's in prison and he has
the coronavirus him and one other inmate
yeah gonna get out he's gonna die any
baby he's had a long day not his face
anything no uh-huh
he's the other dolly dude sir Oh guy he
looks like [ __ ] how about he was crying
whining he that they got it wrong saying
this is wrong
yeah he was uh I mean when 80 women come
out you know maybe maybe it isn't wrong
made some great movies though yeah but
maybe when we got more years here Bob
kept [ __ ] Bill Cosby I don't know cuz
Bill Cosby's problem was was statute of
limitation like after all those years
yeah he got caught up with one woman I
guess was I don't know three counts by
reading he says all three three ten
years so you're telling me
Bill Cosby got less time than Harvey
Weinstein I guess cuz you could only be
cast as my annotation right that just
don't seem right expensive sir full
10-year sentence and he's found a hole
and getting holding it three and he's
blind no he's only get three how long
has he been in there
I'll be out three it'll Cosby I guess he
likes it in there Paley's running [ __ ]
all right yeah telling jokes and [ __ ]
everyone loves them two years then are
September 25th 2018 he gets out like
[ __ ] oh gee yes dude what else you got
Plus everyone in there but knows them
they like him yeah he's not trying to
rape them
[Music]
so the hashtag Kanye West is over party
or like is canceled was trending because
the clip that was released of Taylor
Swift saying that it's speaking to Kanye
saying that like she approved of his
lyric I made that [ __ ] famous in his
song to spiral a couple years ago he
said that he called her and there was
more footage that was released recently
that basically shows he he told her a
part of the verse but he didn't tell her
that part and what didn't Kim say oh I
knew she was gonna do this so I posted
this I record this somebody and she
posted right she posted it but she
didn't post this part and this part came
I haven't seen this what is this have
you seen this is the call
so my next single I wanted you to tweet
it it's the it's a good Friday's who
drop as a good Friday song so that's
what I'm calling you that I wanted you
to put the song out she's uncomfortable
well they did point by Taylor Swift why
am i posting resolve the reason why it
would be happen is because it has a very
controversial line at the beginning of
the song about you okay so it says and
the song is so so dope and I'm literally
sat with my wife with my home management
team with everything and try to rework
this line I've thought about this line
for eight months I've had this line I'll
try to rework it every which way and the
the original way that I thought about it
is the best way but it's the most
controversial way so it's it's gonna go
eminem a little bit so can you brace
yourself for a second oh shut liked it
all right
it's it wasting it you sound sad
no I don't think it's me keep in mind
she's only 18 here okay
it's said I don't think she was 18 she's
like well in her mid-20s when I first
played she's like 30 now he's uh still
young heard it yes she was like huh
what that's too crazy ba ba ba and then
like when ninja from D at work heard it
he was like oh my god this is the
craziest [ __ ] this is why I was really
selling just let me hear it home this is
so yeah I'm already uncomfortable line I
just want to give you some premise of
that right okay so it says to all my
Southside [ __ ] that know me best
I feel like Taylor Swift might only sex
okay yeah oh well this is the thing I'm
calling you because you got an army you
own a country of [ __ ] two
billion people he didn't say why I made
that [ __ ] face yeah he didn't say that
what did you have that written at the
time I am NOT that's what people don't
know maybe it's not enough like but
still but yeah that footage is realer I
might owe me sex but he said I feel like
Taylor I mean mites might have sex well
that's not the problem
after that he goes cuz I made that [ __ ]
famous yeah yeah know what Taylor Swift
was upset about in accept and was
talking about in her Grammy Award speech
but um yeah yeah I had but my whole
thing is is I just need some more
details I'm not defend Connie because
did you have that line written at the
time yeah I guess I'm doin the polite
thing called everything that no one
really know well it's really hard for
someone like Taylor Swift then to kind
of like you know and somebody asked you
that and you feel uncomfortable but
you're embarrassed to be uncomfortable
then that's that's the problem - you
know you understand how like like
certain women would be like well I deal
with that all the time right because you
can say it'd be like if if say say you
guys were listening and somebody was
talking about some insult to Asians okay
even like the Saturday Night Live thing
with a guy used the word [ __ ]
you guys under under pressure because
we're here you might not express your
outrage on camera or it might be
uncomfortable for you to say you're feel
offended by that it might be feeling
maybe some people would be like I don't
like a scene I don't like it but I don't
want but that's a little different I'm
saying I'm saying that like for Taylor
it's hard for her to say to him I don't
like that he's already making it so but
that's I'm in the point because the the
point is is he lied about what a line
was him just saying me and Taylor might
have sex she's like all right I guess
that's not she goes that's not mean I
would give a [ __ ] here here's a promise
he lied about if you would have said and
then I say yeah might have sex cuz I
made that [ __ ] famous she's like no you
can't but make up [ __ ] famous right
also Tanya should know this being the
business he should have went through her
team can soon as I went to her manager
this woman even got the tape right let
me like get the [ __ ] out it everybody's
not and not only that keep in mind also
there's there's a second violation by
Kanye West and Kim Kardashian which was
then to shame Taylor for coming out and
saying but that's not you said yeah and
then then then Kim Kardashian said oh is
it snakes called orous name no now and
all yeah that's right Kardashian went
hard in the paint again super hard so
it's like oh but wait that's that's
interesting so you you knew the truth
and you still sold her down who and who
posted that that clip I'm not no I
believe it was her sister wasn't it I
thought it was I thought it was Kris
Jenner what one of the Jenner's did I
don't know hosted this clip yes I had
the whole no way I thinks I would she do
that
that's what I read we did my promo from
so so these things come out man at the
end of the day it's really interesting
god that's such a bad look for them
that's such a bad look yeah you can't
lie I mean everything I watch half the
documentary on Taylor Swift yeah now if
you were if you were Taylor Swift's
manager be in that situation and the
lyric came out I made that [ __ ] famous
if you were her manager what would you
tell Taylor to do in that situation
ignore her nothing that's right that's
how I feel don't even bring attention to
it
don't tell me you okay didn't know that
all right cool man there oh ah oh wait
it's the JIT national snake day they
have holidays for everybody uh
everything these days
Chinese this price Kimmy can yeah that's
this big Kim and Kanye the most
respectable people in the Shu they lied
about Te'o 1716 and Taylor got a lot of
[ __ ] for this man ah
people keep sailor a lot of sugar water
why don't that we'll have you seen her
year of the documentary she suffers from
horrible depression for it stays off so
how could you not
how could you not man and by the way
major stalking and [ __ ] like that which
they don't talk about she talked about
it in that documentary for you a little
bit about somebody breaking into her
home yeah dude really dangerous people
John having had that yeah God but what a
terrible thing is if you're Kim and
Kanye to like what more do you guys need
why would you need to shame this 25 year
old with this really bad much money do
you mean how much fame do you need
embarrassing tonight but you feel it's
just I hate Barris it's just that it's
it's also like evil like Hollywood not
great [ __ ] man I agree yeah you just
can't lie about that stuff I don't know
man I don't know but again how much did
well I don't know maybe I'm gonna give
enough ground and say did Kim Kardashian
post that thinking maybe they just
showed her that clip was she actually
there when he called her or did did kind
of just show her that clip there's a lot
of different Kanye's the problem out of
all this
honey's that's right she might and there
might have been Mike he might have been
going on what Connie honey look at this
video this me call her her been like
what the [ __ ] really can give me this
I'm gonna post it post it he's like yeah
do that girl that's possible till the
hole out of it all this like the bad
guys Kanye that's [ __ ] up dude this is
just a fun little silly one somebody
caught their neighbor walking their dog
in a dinosaur suit as we do not a
wrestler in an outbreak yes I think the
cops made him go inside or some [ __ ] I
think so hilarious she went an award for
this
worked dude my post makes guy came in a
full hazmat suit dropped off my food
this is how fast he's walking to you
larious to me and you don't even notice
that the dogs wearing a sweater what a
great outfit though
little great cost you my great costume
that's hilarious
shout out shut up [ __ ] this Monday
alright next one is we've been talking
about him quite a bit and unfortunately
passed away any Rogers have we been
talking about yeah his eyes no face and
everything remember yeah how much work
he's had done yeah he was the real deal
that [ __ ] got cestus hang and
write great songs too and that's a great
song The Gambler mhm natural causes it
says he was in hospice for a while 81
hey when you're on the road I didn't
kill him right
no father time I call on all the time
Carl look it's a beast though they say
the human body bray like the longest is
supposed to live apparently is 90 years
some people go farther than that but
after 90 you are really saying with
house money you're playing with house
money my grand my uncle lily is 96
pretty badass was he hiding asleep
was he good though or was he just cause
being a lot as a hundred percent yeah
it's weird he lost his hearing a little
bit but he's after 85 where you know
where you're just kind of a vegetable
with like eyes yeah you don't want that
was very moderate guy did a lot of
reading very refined gentleman and one
thing I don't know that happened to him
was he was when he was 80 like nine he
had real trouble with his joints like
just major problems he started taking
fish oil and he took fish oil and he
walked from 42nd Street to our apartment
57th Street and and that was the first
time I realized that fish oil was the
real deal he said it for me it made a
huge difference so you know he swore by
it do you guys all the difference
between a fish oil and krill oil cuz I'm
everyone's telling me to take krill oil
same thing I guess but krill oil tends
to be less contaminated apparently
because they don't live as long that's
so so I think Crow is the best fish the
best oil to take for those whatever
those no no okay I don't know
thirty-four-year-old California man dead
of coronavirus gotta at Disneyworld yes
the guy had
and pan ammonia so sippin Ouma the
[ __ ] media loves to find those things
well he did die though yeah I mean you
did dive cross you'd have like your team
to help man's family oh yeah you guys
have seen this one before
well that guy's a porn star cuz I'd like
to see some of his work I don't know
what he does he's just gifted I know
that but a lot of people send different
types of links about emergency
situations you click on it's always this
guy so far yeah
alright so Billy Corbin put this out and
one of my friends Dave sent me the
student I thought was fake but this is
an Okeechobee County Commissioner
talking about how to defeat the
coronavirus I'll show you right now
after this one
you got to go to Rex Chapman Rex Chapman
in sirs Twitter Rex Chapman Rex Chapman
he's the best follow but he has he post
this video of this government official
there like a meeting and he's like well
you know there's a serious like
discussion is equally excuse me goes to
the bathroom but forgot he they're miked
up and blows this toilet up in the lady
the lady's trying to get through it
she's like and the thing here she goes
Edna and so the problem is and then you
can go and she's just died laughing I
was laughing so hard keep scrolling down
it's probably I don't know a few days
ago Keith God who is Rex Chapman I'm
sorry he was an NBA basketball player
for a long time great player people
retweet all his [ __ ] so yeah but you
know what it might might be easier go to
mine because he posts so much [ __ ] yours
yeah I go to mine because I reposted it
uh maybe I did it I don't think I did
keep going what do you leave it on his
own Twitter oh yeah
because it's him buddy why is it just
reposting the same [ __ ] but not only is
this six hours ago he must proposal well
so many people retweet it are you on his
profile or just his wall this is Rex
charming I know but tweets replies if
you go to media go to his media that
should help cuz that's just his post I
think so give me that there scenario
again though it's like they're like and
I go like yeah like you know like a
government situation where they're all
like together
March 17th that's going on that far yes
here it is they're just hold on during
the corona device update meeting this
mere excuse himself to the restroom but
forgot to turn off his mic ready which
you turn it on I won't belabor all the
details I'm sure monthly remember Matt
assume local adaptation from last time
and I mentioned he's gonna hit some of
the highlights here in a minute but the
thing is that these deadly infections
there's something we can see about it do
is call on representatives that are
higher I could never get over it
[Music]
mean that he's talking about that's
[ __ ] too funny dude oh look [ __ ] is
that mayor bro turn here
[ __ ] looks like that oh [ __ ] there's
so many it's not to me send that to me
please I'll see TV what's like that
genes that jinx that murder documentary
he got away with killing all these women
like wife after wife after wife and then
a tree I was doing a documentary on him
and he still miked up and he goes the
bathroom he's talked to himself because
of course I killed those [ __ ] people
come on of course the killer but he's my
god yeah so they took him back to court
now I'm gonna shows not as [ __ ] funny
god damn she can't get through it okay
who could uh I could never get through
oh you and me would it be we'd be dead
you and I would be done I mean I mean I
I can't like whatever words I would have
been rolling on we're together and
there's some [ __ ] we shouldn't laugh at
it was the hardest way our lives that
guy came in with that wig I was [ __ ]
dying [ __ ] I was trying to eat the
potato chips I was laughing so [ __ ]
hard he goes woody boys laughing I did I
miss something I'm like that dummy over
there
like a big daggers Brian stupid now
sorry yeah just stupid
even with our old finance what guy me
but I went in to meet with him and he
has this hairpiece on and I just looked
at Brian and I look at the hairpiece and
then we can't stop laughing
oh my god let me see this one okay
alright this is a real Commissioner but
as a paramedic it started to make a lot
of sense one of the things that was
pointed out in this interview with one
of the doctors for most doctors that has
studied the coronavirus says that the
nasal passages passages and the nasal
membranes or the coolest part of the
body that's why the virus tends to go
there until it then becomes healthy
enough to go into the lungs
this sounds really goofy and it did to
me too but it works once the temperature
reaches 136 degrees Fahrenheit the virus
falls apart and just the minutes
disintegrates okay and I said well how
would you get the temperature up to 132
degrees the answer was you use a blow
dryer because it's capable of doing that
so you hold a blow dryer in front of
your face and you inhale with your nose
and it kills all the viruses in your
nose so I would just I would just
caution residents to you know it if
there's lots of misinformation out there
we're hearing and learning a lot on
social media and there's just a lot of
misinformation on how to cure this
disease and you know I I personally
would just leave that to your medical
person I've heard so [ __ ] [ __ ] just
hey why is Danny DeVito trending please
tell me didn't pass away what see it no
he was talking he was he had a thing
stay home I mean I love somebody I mean
we got this virus this pandemic and you
know young people can get it they can
transmit it to old people and they've
seen you no matter their so Governor
Cuomo asked me to ask you please do us a
favor all of us and stay home not spread
this virus
around thank you watch a little TV why
don't ya is it great I love them great
guy a lot of people have been doing that
reaching out to celebrities and social
media influencers to make these videos I
think Kylie Jenner made one recently two
that circulated I would like to know I
understand I just need to know for how
long because I'm not doing it for a
month yeah yeah no I'm not what do you
do what do you like to work yeah twerk
well okay I'm gonna go back to ABC nm
and start acting they're not open well
I'm gonna do it anyway
do it yeah you're like Hindu [ __ ] you
don't know that's what bothers me is I
can't do I can't do anything
I was sure somewhere he could go like
Hawaii or something just escape for
that's what stresses me out is not being
able to do anything and watching things
fall apart that that really I think it
stresses me out because I think that's
how a lot of the world has been for a
long time when a war starts right and
you know that everything you love
everything you know is gone it's gonna
be gone and you can't do anything oh and
by the way you can't go anywhere you
show dramatic will be back dude yeah
[ __ ] you dude how about that Iraq will
be fine
it's gonna bounce back what else you got
gin I like it get me away from this
sourpuss I like your attitude a lot of
this stuff is coronavirus related
unfortunately well what else is there in
the news
no so this I don't know you guys tell me
more about this Trump said he activated
National Guard in California New York
and Washington and he said this is war
but I guess the war against the virus
yeah
so I mean everyone's always like saying
if you go on social media though it
looks scary right all these military
troops coming through like they're gonna
they're gonna like either like make sure
that you guys aren't messing around on
China something like that right wait
apparently they're just there to help
right yeah Yeah right but yeah so that's
it there there's maybe a bunch of
National Guard around this was a little
while ago you almost said that there he
told his workers that they would most
likely die from a car crash then from
the coronavirus
he's right just percentages but now
our mayor our governor Newsom said that
he enlisted Elon Musk and Tim Cook for
help and they're gonna create to our
50,000 masks and ventilators that have a
big one laters and probably we need
testing right let me talk to him
gavage cool first of all congrats on
your hair I like him yeah cuz he's
good-looking no just got beef I don't
agree with don't like him um not from
what I know but I need to do more
research I don't like his politics all
my I have to do more research but I
don't think he's uh alright also chicken
during outbreak
no this is from the New York City Health
Department a jackoff they're giving you
tips on if you want to have sex
these are a bunch of little tips here so
it's been found in feces of the people
who are infected with the virus but not
yet I stay away from poo but now you
hadn't semen or vaginal fluid hmm good
there's some more stuff wash your hands
there's something about [ __ ] to wash
sex toys I don't know if [ __ ] hell
yeah say no fillings ever 100% real work
said that one time he goes he goes my
tip you guys you stick your tongue in a
girl's ass he gets shirt on so [ __ ] it I
was like I was like how saying there I
was like yeah it's so like I feel like a
[ __ ] he made me feel like he was right
in my face because you get [ __ ] on
you've met it's so [ __ ] what house
are okay it made me feel like Taylor
Swift yeah I felt like a [ __ ] I was
like yeah so what I don't I'm not a big
Rimmer it's not a big Rimmer so have sex
with the people close to you don't have
to above the rhythm of sex with people
outside in a movie I'm happy with the
mouth and the other thing mm-hmm
yeah just a couple of tips there New
York really need to put that out Billy
does give me a lot of babies coming yeah
we're on a Boomer our divorces and
babies yeah oh and your boy Takashi
apparently suffers from some underlying
conditions asthma and he wants to be out
of jail immediately because he's
it works on them mm-hmm think it out
soon huh
yeah Carla doesn't get him some blunts
Brian bronchitis tinnitus blood eyes a
perfect victim and that face and those
tattoos are the night huh tough to it's
a tough sell what else yeah that's
pretty much it everything's Corona yeah
pronounced caught on that Donna now
imagine if your own only company Corona
beer they're so [ __ ] do you think so I
know so well they said that it was kind
of like it there was definitely a drop
in sales like millions or whatever but
then it was like a lot of companies had
drops in sales because it's the virus
yeah I'm not buying one I am I want that
negative energy around me man come on
dude don't make him dump why did it why
was it called the corona virus I believe
it's after the shape of the virus
it's a corona shape what is a corona
shape that's a great question I have no
idea
she's what's called code 19 right Ovid
19 yeah Spanish flu Oh
should we just look for Corona shape
what is the original name of the corona
virus do yo crew of ice derive the mics
overnight it's all right
a halo or quarter halo Oh call it the
halo virus that's way cooler okay oh you
got that halo that's way cooler okay but
then the video again would take your
head yeah an angel mm-hmm yeah it's an
interesting shape well it's just a
circle right yeah we could call it but
none paratus there
why'd you have to [ __ ] on Corona beer
dude you could call it anything I agree
but Corona is halo Corona is that
Spanish for halo hmm that's those
Mexican workers that [ __ ] you over
latin derived from asian greek garland
wreath brief interesting
well that's it dudes down give me your
dates son of a [ __ ]
my dates were in April they're all gone
I'll tell you what's funny is they're
like don't worry shop you just cancelled
your up for April we're gonna do in
October like hey shop we just got news
wear your gear I'm gonna do it in two
I'm 21 yeah because they're still not
gonna be ready for theatres
well I wish everybody luck god Bless
America and God bless you you're a
bummer dude why use this as an
opportunity god damn it for whatever
yeah I'm out of here
justify the kids were out